MALE SPEAKER: All
right, everyone.
Welcome to another Authors
at Google event.
Today, we're very pleased to
welcome a true icon in the
Seattle restaurant scene, none
other than Mr. Tom Douglas.
He has over 13 different
restaurants in the area, and
he's actually published a wide
variety of cookbooks as well.
Today he'll be talking to us on
his life, his restaurants,
entrepreneurship, but most
specifically, his latest book,
which is the "Dahlia Bakery
Cookbook," which started out
with a desire to just have
excellent pastry in his
restaurant, and now itself is
a destination on the Seattle
restaurant scene.
So without further ado,
please join me in
welcoming Tom to Google.
Thanks.
TOM DOUGLAS: Thanks.
Thank you, Cliff.
I'll start with I just flew
in from Manhattan.
How many people are
from Manhattan?
How many people were happy not
to be in Manhattan in the last
week, where I've been?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: Yeah, it is kind of
crazy back there right now.
Yesterday morning when I left
for JFK from downtown-- first
of all, I couldn't hardly--
I had to bribe a cabbie to take
me to JFK, $300, because
he didn't want to go, because he
knew what the other side of
it was, which was by the time I
got to the Triborough Bridge
coming out of midtown Manhattan,
there was a traffic
jam from the end of the bridge
on the Manhattan side of the
East River all the way to JFK.
And it was taking some people
eight hours to get from JFK to
downtown Manhattan.
So it is quite an interesting
time in that big massive city.
Our hotel was a block away
from the dangling crane.
Who saw the crane dangling?
I was right there when
it went over.
We heard it.
We were at 55th and 8th
Avenue when it went
over, and kind of freaky.
And what else?
It's just kind of an odd thing
right now in Manhattan.
Above 34th Street, it's like
nothing ever happened, except
that everyone is on the
street, has no subway.
5 million people a day take the
subway there, so they're
all on the streets, and it's
a very interesting time.
I feel thankful to be here.
As we flew out in our plane
right over the New Jersey
coast, we looked down at Staten
Island, Statue of
Liberty, all that kind of area,
and it's just kaput.
So good to be a Googler today in
Mountain View, California.
What you're seeing on
the internet is
actually very true.
We are going to talk about
my book a bit, but I like
restaurants.
We could talk about the book as
much as you like, questions
about pastry.
I'm more interactive.
I'm better interactive than I am
just sitting up here giving
you a speech.
So if you have questions,
jump in at any time.
This is our fourth book.
The rest have been more savory
in nature, including the very
first one, which was flavors
from our first three
restaurants, and then from our
home, and then others.
I have a little book called "I
Love Crab Cakes," which is all
about the crab cakes from the
area where I grew up was on
the Chesapeake Bay--
Newark, Delaware, so
45 minutes from
the Chesapeake Bay.
It's interesting to me that the
change in restaurants to
this day-- and I think it's got
a lot to do with you all--
from the simplest things like
getting a review of your
restaurant.
You still have to be three,
six months, a year later.
You hope that the
local newspaper
would give you a review.
Now you do a little friends
and family event the night
before you open, and you've been
reviewed by 20 people the
next morning.
That's been a big change in
the restaurant business.
I thought the other interesting
thing was during
the recession, that our customer
counts never went
down in our 13 restaurants.
Not one time, not one quarter,
not one minute did we have
less customers than we had
before the recession started.
The customers that came all
spent less, but the customer
counts were there.
And it really gave me pause to
think about why that is.
And this is the secondary
where you all come in, I
think, which is that people
are stuck behind their
computer screens for
so long every day.
There's just this need to get
out, to be with people,
socialize, to have a place to go
outside of your home where
you'd be by yourself again, or
just cooking by yourself.
And I think restaurants have
become the hub of our
communities.
And if you look at
cafeterias here--
I just walked through them with
the chef team, and it's
fascinating to see everyone just
kind of revolve around
the food here at Google.
And I think it's happening
in everyday
restaurants at same time.
People are revolving
around the table.
The good news about that is that
it keeps chumps like me
in business.
The good news is that people
are still talking over the
dinner table, which I think is
the best way for politics and
things of that sort to happen.
It's a good way for small
business to survive, as the
Googles and the Amazons and the
Microsofts all kind of--
Apples all take over the world
in this business structure.
It's a good way-- it's one of
the last bastions of small
business to be out there
surviving, being creative.
And you see so many coffee
shops, and bars, and
restaurants of all sorts
of opening up still.
It's a nice last bastion.
As bookstores go away--
in Paris--
I was in Paris not too long ago,
and it seemed like there
was a bookstore on
every block.
And the leading line
in the Parisian
paper was, poor Paris.
We are out of bookstores,
because all the bookstores
have closed.
And there's still a bookstore
on every block.
Just imagine what it used to
be like, in a literary town
like Paris, and how the
retail has changed.
My book is about family
and friends.
My book's about being the person
at the water cooler to
talk about the hot restaurant
down the street, not about
what you bought at Walmart
yesterday.
It's about not being the last
person with the recipe card
file, about taking the
responsibility of teaching
someone below you, whether it's
generational or familial
or whatever that is, a friend
and coworker, to extend your
recipe card file past
your own kitchen.
It's about enjoying the treasure
that cooking is,
instead of not having
time to cook.
Cooking is a treasure.
I say put your computer and put
your TV in your kitchen
and keep cooking, even if you
have to watch "The Voice"
while you're doing it.
Go for it, nothing
wrong with that.
We found out this morning that
we're number 14 on the New
York Times Bestseller list,
which is very exciting.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM DOUGLAS: I don't know if
that's just cookbooks, or
how-to-do books, or hardcover
books, or whatever that is.
I don't really give a shit.
It's 14 on the New York Times
Bestseller list, and we'll
just leave it at that.
One of my favorite recipes in
here is called schnecken.
Anyone know what that is?
Schnecken, which is a German
word for kind of a cinnamon
roll pull-apart.
We've all had cinnamon
pull-aparts, right?
It's a classic--
maybe we'll haven't.
But sticky buns--
cinnamon, carmel, nuts,
dough-- yeast dough.
And if there's a recipe that
epitomizes why we have a
baking book now in our life,
it's that Grandma Douglas's
Schnecken that I used to smell
as a 10-year-old, and
earlier, I'm sure.
But I remember it
from about then.
Coming downstairs, you could
smell the yeast upstairs in
the bedroom, and grandma was
visiting from Chicago.
And she'd have the big
sticky dough was
rolled out on the table.
And maybe inappropriate, but
at 10 years old, when you
touch that dough, you
just know that it
feels really good.
At 18, you know why it felt
good, because of the whole--
[LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: If you
know what I mean.
If you don't, never mind.
But at 10 years old, you just
know it feels good and it
smells good.
At 18, you just know it
really feels good.
So she would have
it all laid out.
And then you'd come down, and
she might, or might not, in
her younger days-- so in her
50s, 60s, as far as I
remember, she never
let us touch it.
She would always make it and
shoo you away from the table.
She was not the nicest person
in the whole world.
But in her later years, when she
realized that this was a
tradition in our family and
something that she needed to
pass down, she would welcome
you in to do
parts of the process.
So the big thing, maybe two feet
wide, 18 inches this way
to two feet this way.
And she'd have the dough rolled
out with her little
red-handled rolling pin.
And then she might let you
spread the butter on, and then
sprinkle the brown sugar, and
the nuts, and then you just
roll it up into this pinwheel,
this kind of squishy pinwheel.
And then in the 9 by 13-- not
the 9 by 14, and not the 8 by
11-- just had to be the
right size pan--
you would cut them into one-inch
rounds and then pop
them in there, and
they'd bake up.
And then the dangerous part
would happen when they pulled
it out of the oven, and the
hot caramel was bubbling.
And then you'd have to turn it
over, and everyone would have
to clear out while
grandma did this.
Of course, she's this tall and
her arms were this long.
She would do it on her homemade
aluminum trays.
That was kind of a big thing.
She was a crafty person.
So she did these hammered
aluminum--
does anyone remember--
you can see them in-- like
used stores now.
Anyway, she had a bunch of
those, and we had a bunch.
If she had them, we had them.
So turned it out onto that.
And then there was-- it was the
good time to use my girth.
I have six sisters and a
brother, and I've always been
the biggest person
in the family.
I was born 125 pounds.
[LAUGHTER]
I know you probably don't
believe that, but that's
actually true.
And I was the largest baby
in the state of Delaware.
I know.
Just kidding.
But at that time, by 10 years
old, I was by far the largest
child in our house.
Even my brother, who was six
years older than me, was not
larger than me.
So that's just in time to
do the block and tackle.
You just move over and you get
the pieces that you want,
because everyone had their
favorite corner, the center,
the gooey center, the crispy
corner, or whatever.
And then when you go for
the seconds, you
go for what's left.
And it doesn't really matter at
that point, because you're
in heaven with your
sticky buns.
But that's kind of what this
book is all about, is recipes
like that, that are familial,
they've been passed down, they
are doable, approachable.
They are--
in a sense, they're obligations
to my daughter,
who's 22 now, who's been growing
up cooking with me for
the last 15 years in
our home kitchen.
They're an obligation to her,
to get out, get in the
kitchen, and to continue the
process of not letting the
recipe card file stop with me.
Tons of different stuff in
there, so I'm just going to
maybe open it for questions.
We can talk about Seattle.
We can talk about restaurants.
I love restaurants.
I eat in one of mine and
somebody else's every day.
I was in Manhattan two weeks ago
for another event, and I
was there for almost a week.
And we ate in 37 restaurants
in five days, because
that's what I do.
I love restaurants.
I was in Manhattan this time
for almost six days or so.
And I couldn't have even eaten
half of that many.
They weren't open.
Everyone was closed, except
for hotel restaurants.
And then you were on very
limited menus, because they
only had the cooks that they
could keep in rooms upstairs.
And then as soon as the power
went out in southern
Manhattan, on the tip, they
kicked all the cooks and
people out of their rooms,
because then they could sell
out the rooms.
Every hotel room in Manhattan
is booked right now because
people don't have power.
So we can talk about Manhattan
and the floods, being in the
middle of a hurricane.
We can talk about anything
you like.
So I'm going to open up.
Somebody just start us off.
AUDIENCE: If anyone wants to ask
questions, ask for a mic.
TOM DOUGLAS: We can talk
about entrepreneurial.
Does anyone want to
open a restaurant?
Yes?
Do you?
I have a funny story.
You guys might know
who Amazon is.
They're expanding rapidly
in the city of Seattle--
largest urban campus
in the world.
I have three restaurants,
almost--
three restaurants in the middle
of their campus, and I
have two just a block outside
of the campus in South Lake
Union of Seattle.
And we had this whole
building.
It was 20,000 square foot.
And I couldn't decide whether
to do one, two, or three
restaurants in there.
I didn't want to do one,
because it was too big.
But it's two levels, so
I decided to do three
restaurants, one on the bottom,
one upstairs, and then
one little one just for the
Amazonians in the back, a
little Tibetan dumpling bar.
Because I had a Tibetan
chef on staff
for the last 17 years.
So I got hold of--
I asked the guy who was a group
leader at Amazon for his
list of people that reported to
him, if I could do a little
survey so I could find out what
the Amazonians wanted
next to their offices.
And talk about different
business cultures.
You guys seem like you might
have a pretty strong culture
around here.
Something tells me-- yellow
bikes and stuff, volleyball.
So I wrote a note to all
600 of these folks.
And I said, if you could
put any restaurant--
Stunned by this, I'm well-known
known in Seattle.
If you could put any restaurant
right next to your--
if you could own
any restaurant.
Cost is no object.
Doesn't cost you a dime.
You want your favorite
restaurant right
next to your office.
What would it be?
And I got 150 responses.
72% said exactly the same thing,
which is, I thought, an
incredible number to have the
similar response, out of all
the possibilities
of restaurants.
Anybody here want to
take a gander?
You say you want to open--
what would you open?
If you could open a restaurant
right next to your office,
have it be your favorite place,
all your friends would
come, what would it be?
AUDIENCE: Seafood.
TOM DOUGLAS: Seafood?
Of any sort?
You just like seafood?
So is that sushi?
Is that grilled salmon?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Grilled and fried [INAUDIBLE].
TOM DOUGLAS: Delicious.
Sounds great.
Anybody else?
Is that a family recipe?
Do you guys have a
family tradition?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TOM DOUGLAS: So you'd bring
your family into it.
You're passionate about--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOM DOUGLAS: OK.
There you go.
It's right in here.
Anybody else want to jump in?
What would you build right
next to your office?
AUDIENCE: Speaking of Manhattan,
I would say the
halal cart down at
53rd and 6th.
TOM DOUGLAS: A la carte?
AUDIENCE: No.
Halal chicken cart.
TOM DOUGLAS: Oh, the halal
carts, one of those little
quick skewer jobs?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
TOM DOUGLAS: With the
heavy fried rice?
Oddly enough, they were
not out either.
That was another odd thing about
Manhattan during the
storm, was they just
disappeared.
They started showing
up yesterday.
So halal carts, chicken
skewers-- anybody else?
Nobody else here wants to--
look at all the white chef
coats in the back.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Franklin's barbecue.
TOM DOUGLAS: Franklin's
barbecue.
What do you like about it?
AUDIENCE: Everything
on the tray.
TOM DOUGLAS: Some good smoky
brisket, beans, mac and
cheese, cornbread.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM DOUGLAS: Meat, meat, meat.
AUDIENCE: Now, the funny thing
is I eat meat about once a
week, but that would
be my last meal.
TOM DOUGLAS: That would be it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TOM DOUGLAS: And where
is Franklin's?
AUDIENCE: Austin, Texas.
TOM DOUGLAS: Ah.
So I go to the Salt Lick, just
south in Lockhart, in the
barbecue belt.
AUDIENCE: That would be a backup
on an all-star team.
It's very good.
TOM DOUGLAS: Ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: Have you
been to Smith's?
AUDIENCE: What's Smith's?
TOM DOUGLAS: Smith's, it's
got the black crusted
brisked down in--
AUDIENCE: That's everywhere.
TOM DOUGLAS: Yeah, but this--
AUDIENCE: Are you talking
about Smitty's?
TOM DOUGLAS: Smitty's, down--
it's near Lockhart, but it's
not in the town of Lockhart.
AUDIENCE: Smitty's
is in Lockhart.
TOM DOUGLAS: Maybe
it's Smitty's.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM DOUGLAS: Kreuz is
a more Germans.
I'm not a big fan
of Kreuz market.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TOM DOUGLAS: Yeah, that's
not my favorite.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I always thought Salt Lick
was slightly German too.
TOM DOUGLAS: It is slightly, but
to me, it's a little bit
more Texas.
Kreuz's-- anyway,
so barbecue is--
getting back to our point.
We don't want to--
So anybody--
so here's my point.
Here's what I was
trying to get at
with my Amazon question.
72% of 150 people that responded
to me said, well,
really I just want cheap.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: You could open
anything in the world right
next to your office.
All they worried about
was the price of it.
And that is definitely
an Amazon culture.
And if you go to their offices,
their desks are made
out of old wood doors,
and on saw horses
and things like that.
It's just fascinating
to me, the culture.
I bet if I did the same thing
anonymously here, I bet it
would be a very different
answer.
Because this place seems much
more food-oriented.
Kind of fun.
Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: Maybe following up
on that, what do you think
about the food truck culture?
Are they--
do you feel threatened
by that?
Is it unfair competition?
TOM DOUGLAS: Is it unfair?
I mean, if you were to look at
the apples to apples, yeah,
it's a little unfair.
Do I feel threatened?
No.
What's the upside
to the truck?
There's really not
a lot of upside.
You can do as many meals as you
can do a day out of it.
And so from a financial
perspective, would I ever do a
truck personally?
There's just not enough in it.
Passionate, young person's
job-- absolutely.
Great place to try a concept,
absolutely--
same as a farmer's
market, though.
I think they're interesting
and fun.
You know, the new Amazon, they
just announced three million
more square feet in
downtown Seattle.
And they're building a truck
rodeo spot in the middle of
the campus.
They really like it.
Those workers really like it.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Cheap.
TOM DOUGLAS: It's cheap.
It's really cheap.
So no, I don't feel
threatened.
But it is what it is.
In Portland right now, there's a
lot of food trucks for sale.
It's gone over the
tipping point of
viability in Portland.
And so that's where we
just bought ours.
We're moving our little Tibetan
dumpling business into
a truck, but only because my
Tibetan chef, who's 65, could
not handle the business
at our other place.
So I'm moving her
out of there.
I never wanted to open
outside of Seattle
until my kid was grown.
Now she's grown, so maybe
we'd think about that.
We're actually talking with a
company in South Korea right
now for Serious-- about
50 Serious Pies.
In Paris and London and Milan,
we're kind of in negotiations
right now about Serious Pies,
what do we want to do with it.
Six months after we opened, I
was offered $5 million for
Serious Pie--
the concept--
for 300 units in North America,
and I had to be at
the opening of every unit.
That was my only
responsibility,
other than the recipes.
And it just didn't feel right,
just didn't feel good.
Today, seven years later,
would I do it?
I would think about
it more seriously.
But Serious Pie is
just a terrific
little organic pizzeria.
How many people have been
to Serious Pie?
A couple?
Serious Pie is what happens when
a fine dining chef thinks
about pizza, and we put our same
values into pizza that we
put in, say, at the Dahlia
Lounge, our kind of flagship
fanciest restaurant.
When we put those same values
onto a pizza, things change.
You expect different
end results.
And I don't mean that in
a, wow, my pie's better
than your pie way.
It's just changed.
Things that we wouldn't
accept went away.
Like, by putting cheese on a
pizza, when you put it into
the oven, and then baking it,
you get a different product
when it comes out.
You don't get cheese anymore.
You get the whey and the milk
product, and you get a
separation of the fat
out of the cheese.
You end up with two
different things.
That's why when you order to-go
pizza and you get it at
your house, it comes with that
oil slick on the top.
What is that?
That's your cheese that has been
overcooked, and the fat
and the whey is separated.
And that's what ends up being--
because cheese is fat.
It's going to turn greasy
when you break it.
What happens when you make
mayonnaise and it separates?
Separate the egg and the mustard
and the lemon juice
from the fat.
It separates.
You wouldn't want to eat just
the greasy part of the
mayonnaise, just the fat part.
You want to eat the combination,
the whipped
together, the emulsified fat.
So in Serious Pie, we worked on
the crust for three months.
We kept working on it,
working on it.
Because we started with the
assumptions that it has to be
similar to what we know.
And then as we got into it more
and more, we realized
that it has to be opposite of
what we know if it's going to
be a game changer.
Why would I open a pizzeria if
it wasn't a game changer?
I'm not in it for the money.
I'm in it for the passion.
I like to make money, but it's
not my end-- my end game is to
make as good a pie as I
can make, something
that makes me happy.
And so three months later,
we had this crust.
It started with high-gluten
flour.
All the other pizzerias, all
these Neapolitan style pizzas
they cook at 800 degrees, 850,
for a minute and a half with
double zero flour,
totally opposite.
Very low gluten--
very high gluten in our flour.
We have a much more
structured dough.
It takes three days to make.
When we run out of dough
tonight, we can't make any
more dough.
It's three days for that
dough to happen.
So we just close
the restaurant.
It boils up-- the black boils
on it happen beautifully.
It's probably the only thing
we changed about the pie.
Because I love the black
boils on a crust.
And my customers were sending
it back before they
would even try it.
They'd say, hey,
this is burnt.
And we were having this issue.
And finally, I gave
a little bit and
sent it out dark brown.
But I love the black
boils, that crusty,
black, burnt flavor.
We just--
simple things like extra
virgin olive oil.
We use the best cheeses in the
world, and less of them, and
then we treat them correctly.
How many people put herbs on the
pizza after it comes out
of the oven?
Herbs lose 90% of their flavor
if they're cooked.
If you put them on after and let
the residual heat of the
pie bring out the fragrance of
those herbs, you have a much
different pizza experience.
And so that's what we do.
We have cheese and
herb afterwards.
We put fresh extra virgin olive
oil on afterwards so
they get that good
olive-y flavor.
And then we cook at 625 degrees
for six and a half to
seven minutes.
So we had a real structured
crust already, and then that
slow bake cooks it all the way
through, compared to the
minute and a half at 850.
So it's just a pie that
we thought about.
And that's what happens when you
think about something and
throw away all the rules.
And it sounds like maybe that
happens around here
once and a while too.
AUDIENCE: Tom, I had a
quick question too.
You've worked with the same
co-author for many your
cookbooks--
TOM DOUGLAS: Shelley?
AUDIENCE: --and this
one specifically.
Could you describe how that
collaboration process works,
and how you go about
writing your books?
TOM DOUGLAS: Sure.
So Shelley Lance is
my co-author.
She was a saute cook for me at a
restaurant before I owned my
own places.
So we've worked together now for
27 years, I want to say.
And she's crotchety.
She is a whiner.
And so her, a busy night on the
line just was not the best
thing ever.
And so we always looked for jobs
to get Shelley off the
line, because she had the best
palate in the company.
And I didn't want to lose her
sense of food, just very, very
organic, natural, passionate
sense for food.
And so we finally moved her into
the baking, and then she
started doing the baking.
And then once we got to be
multiple units, once we got to
be three restaurants,
she became our
quality control person.
So her job was to eat in each of
the restaurants every week,
and then write a
report for me.
Because at that point, I was
starting to travel more.
And now was she can't even keep
up with that, now that we
have 13 places.
She is just our blog editor,
and our author.
And she is really persnickety.
"Food and Wine" magazine in
their review called it the
best-tested recipes they'd
ever come across, because
Shelley does that.
Every recipe is tested
five times--
three by chefs, two
by home cooks--
and Shelley is the coordinator
of all of that.
So when you go to make the
effort to cook, it's going to
come out the way we tell you
it's going to come out.
So Cliff, that is why,
where we went to.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How long does it
take to write a cookbook?
TOM DOUGLAS: So the question is,
how long does it take to
write a cookbook?
AUDIENCE: From start
to finish.
TOM DOUGLAS: From
start to finish.
Well, if you're as ADD as
me, it takes longer.
If I were to just sit down and
do it, I could do it in less
than a month--
not all the testing, and
not all that part.
But writing the book, I
could do it no time.
But doing it on airplanes and
weekends and all the times
that you happen to be in the
mood to write the right part
of the book, just the head notes
and the introduction and
things of that sort, they
take me a long time.
We worked on this book
for almost two years.
And I would say it's still
old school publishing.
Things are changing.
I'm surprised that my publisher
took that long, honestly.
When I did my first
book, it was a
two-an-a-half-year process.
Now it's a two-year process.
I would've thought
they'd be faster.
The good news is that it's
a really good book.
Came out nice.
Ed Anderson, a San Francisco
photographer, did the
photographs.
It's printed in country, which
makes it easier for reprints,
and for all of those
kind of things.
That's a big challenge, to not
spend three months on a boat
coming from someplace else.
So that's been nice, compared
to my other books.
It's already in its
second printing.
It's been out for a week.
My first book is in
its 14th printing.
So, I mean, one of the things
I'm most proud about is, our
books work.
And that takes extra time.
And that takes dollars, to make
a recipe five times and
pay five different chefs to do
it, and then to do it again a
sixth time for a photograph.
We spend a lot of money
to make sure that
everything is good.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to touch more
on what you said, that
how Americans are having this
attachment to restaurants.
We're, like, using it as
a hub of socializing.
Have you seen that to be the
case in other countries?
I've been told that other
countries don't go to
restaurants as much as we do.
I wanted to get your perspective
on that.
TOM DOUGLAS: Well,
I think that--
I think every country
goes to restaurants.
I would--
if you go to Hong Kong, the
restaurants are packed.
It's hard to break out which
is tourism, which is not.
Same in San Francisco.
San Francisco gets over 40
million tourists a year.
Seattle gets 10.
It's hard to say
who gets what.
If you took tourism out of San
Francisco, you'd have half the
number of restaurants
to choose from.
It's an important part of
giving you the depth and
breadth of restaurants
that you have.
In other countries, having just
spent five weeks in Paris
last October, you know, you
could put dog shit on a plate.
There are so many people there
looking for cuisine
traditional.
And there's not a Parisian
cooking it.
There's a lot of North Africans
cooking it, just like
there's a lot of Latinos
in our kitchens.
They're not connected to the
food in the same way.
They're certainly
terrific cooks.
But I don't know how it is
down here, but in our
kitchens, when one of our Latino
cooks wants to eat, he
or she would definitely rather
eat off of their own staff
meal than any of our menus.
And that's what you find
in Italy, and in--
like, in Tuscany or areas like
that, you go to 10 restaurants
in Florence.
Nine of them have exactly
the same menu.
So they eat out, but if you ask
a Parisian today, where do
you want to go for dinner
tonight, they go out for
French food.
They don't go out and so, I feel
like Vietnamese tonight,
or I feel like Chinese,
or I feel like
Mexican food tonight.
They don't think that way.
That's a uniquely
American thing.
And I'm thankful for it.
My food definitely
reflects that.
It sure seems like the
restaurants and cafes are busy
everywhere.
London, you could hardly
get into a restaurant.
Paris, the same way.
I went thinking no reservations
and no stars, and
the only thing I had to change
was no reservations.
I had to get reservations, or
else you eat at the worst of
the worst restaurants
in Paris.
In Milan, some of the best food,
going, but got to have a
reservation.
But it's very much
Milanese food.
There's a reason for that.
People, they live on tourism.
And when people get there,
they don't want to
eat Chinese in Italy.
Whereas in America, we're
a melting pot.
You'd just as soon have-- we
have some of the best Chinese
restaurants in the world right
here in this country.
Any other thoughts about
restaurants?
Yes?
OK.
Oh, there you are.
AUDIENCE: How do you stay--
or maybe you don't.
How do you stay on top of food
trends, and, I don't know,
embrace them, and then
kind of make sure--
TOM DOUGLAS: That we're
part of the--
part of the conversation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
Without kind of coming
in too late.
TOM DOUGLAS: Well, it's probably
the same as you do.
You look around, and I eat
around everywhere, to make
sure that what we're doing is
current and now and delicious.
And I got to say, the left coast
of this country is the
trendsetter.
When you look at what's
happening in San Francisco,
and Seattle, and Portland, and
Vancouver, BC, and LA, there's
just no doubt that the best food
is happening on this side
of the country.
You look in London and Paris,
some of the best restaurants
in Paris are being run by
American chefs, whether it's
spring or Verjus.
It's not just American chefs,
but it's French chefs that
have been on the road through
the Americas.
It's fascinating.
This country is so willing to
accept change and growth,
unlike other cultures in the
food world, that it's probably
why Google does what it does.
We're so willing to accept
the next new thing.
And that's harder for other
countries that are steeped in
tradition than a young country
like this one, a melting pot
like this one.
I think the trends really
are leaning themselves--
I know just Amazon alone in my
neighborhood in Seattle has
2,000 Indians working there.
And we have virtually no modern
Indian restaurant in
the city, nothing that I would
be proud to say, this is a
great Indian restaurant.
You should check this out.
It's just the way it is.
So there's no doubt that modern
Indian is going to be
the next wave of food.
And we're already getting--
there's one in Vancouver that
I love called Vij's.
And we're getting a second--
the new offshoot of Vij's is
happening in Seattle, in Lake
Union, in two weeks.
So that's what I'm
looking for.
And then I'm looking to break
India down like China got
broken down, the Szechuan
and Hunan and Canton.
And as soon as India gets broken
down, I think that's
going to be very interesting,
not just southern and
northern, but regional
aspects of Indian
food, and Asia in general.
AUDIENCE: Typically the chefs
that I watch on TV, like
Gordon Ramsay, they have
a signature dish.
And I was wondering, like,
what would be--
TOM DOUGLAS: His signature
dish is fuck you.
AUDIENCE: Really?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: That's all
he says, isn't it?
Every other word's a bleep.
AUDIENCE: I think I chose
a bad example.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: Would you ever work
at a restaurant if that's
what you thought that
they were like?
AUDIENCE: No.
I wouldn't.
TOM DOUGLAS: No.
It's ridiculous.
AUDIENCE: But, you know, what
would be a dish that you would
like to be associated
with the most,
like, one of your dishes?
TOM DOUGLAS: Of my dishes?
It's probably with my oldest
restaurant, which is the
Dahlia Lounge.
And we do this slow roasted duck
there that gets marinated
for two days, and then
five hours slow
roasted over a wood fire.
And it just is beautifully
rendered and gets to a
fall-off-the-bone texture, which
I don't think you see
much in duck these days.
Everywhere you go, it's either a
confit leg and a sliced rare
breast, or it's just
the rare breast.
Well, I like a whole roasted
duck, just like I like a
fall-off-the-bone chicken.
And we do it there.
It's got a kind of a--
we call it a [? diki ?] rub, or
Chinese 12 spice, or some--
it's got this kind of
aromatic rub on it.
And then when we pull that off,
we let them cool, and
they're just these lacquered
brown color from the rub and
the wood smoke.
And then we break them down into
a thigh leg piece and a
breast piece.
And then when you come into the
restaurant and you order
it, we take those and we put
them skin side down on a
sizzle platter, and just render
that skin until--
it looks black in the dining
because the dining room is
naturally darker than
the kitchen.
But it's just this caramelized
toasty brown, like the outside
of a toasted almond that has
the skin still on it.
It's dark like that.
And it is glorious.
And we'll serve it
with a little
quick stir fried gai-lan--
a Chinese broccoli-- or a wide,
fresh rice noodle made
in Chinatown in our city--
Chu Chong noodle company.
I love that kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: What do you think of
the technological advances of
cooking, like using dry ice,
and the other things that
Myhrvold is kind of exploring?
TOM DOUGLAS: I think it's all
perfectly interesting.
The young chefs are really
enamored with it, which I
think anything that gets them
engaged is great by me.
In "The Modernist Cuisine"-- do
you know what he's talking
about, the book "Modernist
Cuisine"?
Where it talks about, not just
the new cooking styles, but
also it explains cooking in
general, from what happens in
a hot wok, to what happens
on your charcoal grill.
How is that affecting the meat
or fish that you put right on
top of it, and the
caramelization process, and
all of those sorts of things.
I think it's interesting now,
right now, Williams Sonoma,
Sur La Table, they all have home
sous-vide machines that
you can buy and take home
and do your own process.
But sous-vide's been around
for 60 years.
That's nothing new.
I was using sous-vide on
Northwest Airlines,
15, 20 years ago.
I love that it explains what's
going on in your kitchen.
They cut the microwave
in half to show you
exactly what it is.
I've been to the lab.
I had my 42-course dinner
in the lab.
I got to tell you, it's
not all that.
It's certainly not
more delicious.
It's just more--
it's interesting.
It's centrifuges and
liquid nitrogen.
I had what he called
the perfect ribs.
I think in the new home
version of "Modernist
Cuisine," they call it perfect
ribs, where you drop them into
a nitrogen container and
freeze them rock hard--
just the outside, just
freeze the skin
rock hard on the outside.
So it's like five seconds in
nitrogen, and then 10 seconds
in a deep fryer, because all he
wants to do is not change
the structure of the meat on
the inside with either
manipulation.
So he wants that perfectly
smoky rib on the inside.
But by freezing the outside
first, it takes that much
longer in the fryer to heat the
inside, so when you do the
deep fryer, it only changes the
skin texture, which gives
you a crisp skin.
And the inside stays exactly
the same because it was so
cold to begin with, when
it went in the fryer.
So those are the kind and
thoughtful things that come
out of that.
I'm all for it.
At the end of the day, food
manipulation is just that,
whether you're doing it with
nitrogen, or if you're doing
it on charcoal grill.
You are manipulating
an end product.
So at the beginning of the
day-- so that's at
the end of the day.
At the beginning of the
day, what's important?
What kind of salmon is it?
Where do they come from?
How is it caught?
Is it sustainably caught?
So are you leaving fish for
the next generation?
So then, how was it caught?
Was it bled right after it was
brought onto the boat?
Was it packed in ice?
Was it taken to shore on a day
boat rather than sitting out
on a trawler for the
three or four days?
Was it then flown to
your restaurant?
When you touch it, does
it have bright
eyes and bright scales?
When you run your finger across
the flesh, does the
flesh come off on your finger,
or does it stay right on the
fish where it should be, which
suggests that it's only been
out of the water a day or two?
What's important for a young
chef is to know those details.
Because if you don't start with
a great product, I don't
care what you do at the end of
the day, you're going to have
shitty fish, just plain
and simple.
So you have to have your basics
down to understand what
a good fish is to begin with,
and to buy the best products.
And then as I tell my chefs,
is, get out of the way.
Don't screw it up.
It's like, what can you do to
a 25-pound beautiful king
salmon from the Copper River.
What can you do that's going
to be better than that?
You can't.
AUDIENCE: You can dry it.
TOM DOUGLAS: You can dry it?
Yeah, you can--
you know what I'm saying.
All you can do is try to get
out of the way and let that
fish be everything it can be.
And to put it into a sous-vide,
and to all this
stuff, infuse it with herbs, and
all those kind of things,
you have to have a pretty big
ego to think that you're going
to do something better than that
fish is already showing.
Or, then that fish could be done
in a $10 Chinese bamboo
steamer with a little bit of
green onion and a little bit
of garlic or a fresh
shred of ginger.
What can you do that's
better than that?
I'm sorry.
You can't.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple questions.
One is, what is your
favorite of your
restaurants that you have?
TOM DOUGLAS: My favorite is--
only because it's where my
office is, it's where the
Palace Kitchen is.
And it also serves full
dinner until 1 AM,
and I'm a late eater.
We have restaurants that go
til midnight, and we have
catering that goes often late.
We have concessions at the local
theaters that go late.
And I love just bringing my
team back and eating late
dinner at the Palace Kitchen.
AUDIENCE: And then my other
question was, when I moved
down here a year ago, there was
this big craze in Seattle
about the menu-less restaurants,
where you just
tell them what you're allergic
to, and then they
just provide food.
Have you thought about doing
a concept like that?
TOM DOUGLAS: No.
I'm not about the chef.
I'm about you, the customer.
And maybe that's totally what
you're interested in, but when
I go to a restaurant,
I like a menu.
When the chef's--
I just ate in New York, and I
happened to run into some of
my favorite chefs.
I ran into Jean-Georges
Vongerichten at Jean Georges.
I ran into Mario Batali at
Babbo, Todd English at Todd
English food halls.
I mean, it was crazy.
I ran into Daniel
at Cafe Boulud.
I know all these-- these
are my peers.
I want to see what
they're doing.
I don't want to just walk in and
have whoever they have the
kitchen do what they do.
I want a menu.
I want to mix and match.
I might order four entrees.
It's what I do.
So no, I'm more about being the
customer and looking for
that great experience.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Giada De Laurentiis is one of
my favorite Food Network
personalities.
TOM DOUGLAS: Me too.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: For other
reasons, probably.
AUDIENCE: I love the way
she says "spa-gee-ti."
TOM DOUGLAS: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: But I was wondering
if you could talk about the
episode when she tried your
donuts, and kind of what that
interaction was like.
TOM DOUGLAS: Sure.
Well, just to go back a couple
of years from that, I was
doing a cover shot for
Thanksgiving for "Food and
Wine" magazine.
We were on the cover maybe seven
or eight years ago now.
And they sent a crew
out from New York.
And of course, I keep all sorts
of china at my house.
I keep every set of china for
each of my restaurants, so
that when I'm trying something
at home, I can see what it
looks like on a plate.
That's where it would
be served.
And then I have 15 sets of china
of my own at my home, so
we have 30 sets of china
at our house.
And so I'm getting
these calls.
I have platters from
all over the world.
I've got lots of stuff.
If you want to see my kitchen,
as a matter of
fact, something kitchen--
fine cooking.
"Fine Cooking" magazine, just
in the online version of
exploration of our kitchen.
And it's in the magazine too,
but the online is a more
narrated version of
our home kitchen.
But anyway, so "Food
and Wine" calls.
Will you do this?
Of course I'll do it.
Cover of "Food and
Wine" magazine?
Sure.
So then they sent
out their team.
Well, the assistant food stylist
on that particular
shoot was Giada De Laurentiis,
before she got famous.
And you know, of course,
who she's family of?
Dino De Laurentiis,
the famous movie
Hollywood movie producer.
That's her grandfather.
And a lot of people don't
remember, but he tried to do a
big food thing in New York
called "The Dino De Laurentiis
Food Show." And it
was based on--
have you ever been to Harrods
in London, in the food thing
in the basement?
Or Takashimaya in Tokyo,
with the big food
center in the basement?
It was based on that,
in Manhattan.
You've been to Eataly
now in New York?
Anybody been to Eataly, where
you have that kind of food
interspersed with shopping,
or to Peck in Milan?
Really incredible mix of food
and restaurant and cafe.
And he went--
nine months, the whole place
went under, in Manhattan-- her
grandfather.
So anyway, she was the assistant
food stylist.
Then she went on to get
her own little show.
And between the teeth and the
cleavage, she is just kick--
and that little--
what did you say,
"spa-get-tee"?
Yeah, exactly.
She has killed it.
So she called me--
her producer called me and
said can Giada come in?
And I said, certainly,
absolutely.
And that was pretty much it.
We sat and chatted for
a bit on camera.
And I don't think I made
the camera at all.
I have a face made for radio,
as they like to say.
And I don't think I was in
that shot at all on TV.
And she just said it.
And you know, Tyler Florence
said the same
about Serious Pie.
And that was a huge--
they keep replaying that too.
And you know, I was on "Iron
Chef." I was up against
Morimoto on "Iron Chef." And
they keep replaying that also,
which is kind of interesting.
Whenever they say it's just OK
to be on the show, it's not
better to win or lose.
It's better to win.
Because every time they
show it, like,
it's been on 100 times.
I'm 100 and 0.
Every time, I win.
It's quite fantastic.
And every time they show
Giada or Tyler, the
restaurants win again.
We can just feel the punch the
next morning of people that
have seen it the night before.
So it's kind of interesting.
AUDIENCE: What's your
comfort food?
Or what would you want in the
center of-- near you, the
question you asked--
TOM DOUGLAS: Boy.
You know, what's so fun
now is to have my
daughter cook for us.
That's pretty comforting
to watch her
stroll about the kitchen.
And she still thinks
I'm an OK dad.
I think that's pretty cool.
My comfort food?
I mean, I think something like
orecchiette with broccoli rabe
and Italian sausage.
I could eat that every--
once a week, at least.
I love that kind of stewy
kind of thing.
That same salmon that I
talked about, just--
I take up a bamboo steamer.
I take a plate with a well.
I put my two pieces of fish when
my wife and I are eating,
grapes, fresh ginger, squeeze
little bit of the ginger
juice, little soy sauce, a
little pat of butter, maybe if
I have it, a couple slivers of
green onion, a little sake or
white wine.
And then my next level up--
those steamers are
layered, right?
So next level up, I'd put a
little fresh baby bok choy.
And then in my rice cooker, I
have rice with a little-- one
pod of star anise in there.
So I have this beautiful kind of
fragrant steamed rice, this
perfectly steamed gorgeous piece
of fish, and a hot al
dente broccoli rabe.
I just think that's comfort.
So if I was cooking for myself,
that's my comfort food.
If my wife's cooking, I like
the sausage and rabe.
She's Italian Greek.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any favorite
restaurants in San Francisco?
TOM DOUGLAS: Favorite
Of course I do.
I'm part owner of a restaurant
in San Francisco.
Has anyone been to Prospect?
Yeah?
What did you think?
Don't say anything bad.
Yeah, I liked it.
That's sort of OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM DOUGLAS: You live above it
and you haven't been there?
You cheap son of a bitch.
What do you--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: I'm trying
to make a living here!
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'd like to go, it's
a nice restaurant, but it's
like, I live right--
I don't know.
I've been putting it off.
TOM DOUGLAS: I guess.
So Prospect is a sister
restaurant to Boulevard.
And I've been long many year
friends with Nancy Oaks, who
owns Boulevard.
They were going to start a new
restaurant group down here.
And I don't even know
the name of it.
I invested so long ago.
I've invested in a ton
of restaurants.
I never get a dime back.
And so here, I'm part
owner of Prospect.
I kind of had visions at some
point that maybe Serious Pie
would come down here and
they would run it.
That's an interesting
angle to me.
AUDIENCE: Do it.
TOM DOUGLAS: Do it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
TOM DOUGLAS: But, you
know, what's your
favorite pizza down here?
Like, A16 or something
like that, right?
That's a very different pie.
That's more the Neapolitan
style pie.
And it's just--
I'm always curious if my pie
will go well someplace else,
because it's so different.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM DOUGLAS: Anywhere.
First potato pizza I ever
had, the potato rosemary
pizza was in Rome.
And I was just smitten by it.
It was so delicious.
But in Rome, the crusts
are very thick.
A lot of the pizzerias in Rome,
they're kind of rolled
out into sheet pans, and more
like a focaccia base, and then
the toppings right on there.
Finally, someone in a chef
coat speaking up,
representing.
AUDIENCE: I'm off shift.
TOM DOUGLAS: You're off shift.
Did I scare everyone else away,
or do they have to go
back to work?
AUDIENCE: They had to
go back to work.
TOM DOUGLAS: OK.
AUDIENCE: I start super early.
I want to own my own bakery.
I'm in the very, very beginning
stages right now.
[INAUDIBLE] working.
And, what would you say
is your best advice?
I mean, the first few things
you think of when you're
talking to someone who
wants to start--
TOM DOUGLAS: Right.
So have you worked in
other bakeries?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I've been in the industry for
almost nine years now.
TOM DOUGLAS: And have you worked
in some independent
bakeries, so you know
the pitfalls of
doing everything yourself?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
TOM DOUGLAS: Because sometimes
people forget about, you have
to do the books, and you
have to do the hiring.
AUDIENCE: That's my hardest
part right now.
TOM DOUGLAS: You can't just
make cookies, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TOM DOUGLAS: You have to get
all that other stuff done.
Have you been in bakeries
that you like?
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
There's lots in the
city that I love.
SusieCakes, I kind of want to go
that direction of pies and
cookies and bars, and still
cupcakes, but not--
everyone's cupcakes right
now, and I don't
want to only do that.
TOM DOUGLAS: Right.
I went to-- this morning, I went
to Craftsman and Wolves.
Have you been there yet?
AUDIENCE: No.
TOM DOUGLAS: On Valencia.
It's down near where
Tartine is.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TOM DOUGLAS: And that's much
more of a Pierre Herme style
bakery out of Paris, very
chi-chi, a little bit
laudreeish, without the
drama, but the same
kind of looking pastries.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
TOM DOUGLAS: Interesting
to try, but curious
if they make it.
It's a hard sell in this town to
sell $7, $8, $10 desserts,
this big, in a place where you
don't really have any seating.
So I'll be curious
how that goes.
What else would I say?
Know your neighborhood.
Know your customer.
Know what you want.
And then be willing to make the
adjustments once you get
open, to let your ego get out of
the way and realize that if
these folks don't walk
through your front
door, you're screwed.
And they might once, but they
have to walk through
more than one time.
You have to learn a customer
service that is inviting and
makes them want to come back.
And that's the number
one thing.
So many chefs go in, they want
to open their own place
because they want to
cook their food.
Well, screw you.
Your food is their food.
That's who you owe to.
And if they don't come back and
vote for you with their
dollars, you're done.
And that's why you see the
restaurant churn so often.
Because 75% of restaurants go
out of business through
employee theft.
And the other 25% go out of
business because the chefs are
stupid, and they're egomaniacs
and they can't
get their act together.
They have their tunnel vision
on what they do rather than
business as a bigger picture.
Employee theft, you've probably
all benefited from.
When's the last time you went to
a restaurant where you knew
the bartender, he handed you
a drink, didn't charge you?
That's employee theft.
I'm sure he didn't go to the
till and pay for it himself.
It's the most-- it's nice.
We call it customer
service sometimes.
But that's just-- that's
employee theft.
And it happens through
the back door.
It happens through
the front door.
And it is something that
you can't really stop.
You just have to mitigate
the damage from it.
But that's something to think
about building into your
pricing structure.
And in bakeries, it's
all about waste.
What do you do with those
cookies you didn't sell today?
There's a lot of--
you have to-- if you make 20
cookies, you can't think--
if you made 24 cookies, say, out
of a recipe, and you think
how to price those cookies, it's
not just the ingredients
of the cost of the dough, or the
labor it takes you to make
the 24 cookies.
It's at the end of the
day, how many did you
have to throw away?
So if you had to throw away
six of the 24, you have to
build the cost of those six back
into your first 18, so
that you know what you
should properly be
charging for the cookie.
Unless you want to have--
unless you build in that number,
your numbers aren't
going to work.
Be thinking about
those things.
And always, you can email me.
I'm tom@tomdouglas.com.
And I really believe in
mentorship, and I'm happy to
share any sort of numbers
or anything like that.
AUDIENCE: One final
question then.
How much of your cuisine in
your business do you think
just strictly comes
out of Seattle?
Do you think you would have had
a different path if you
started in Miami or another--
Chicago, another cultural
center?
And what you see is really
next for your empire?
TOM DOUGLAS: My empire
is kind of weird.
You know, I'm the chef
for Amtrak Railroad.
You probably didn't know that.
I'm the chef for Macy's
Corporation, one of 15 of us
on the culinary council
at Macy's.
I'm the chef for Columbia
Crest Winery, the second
largest winery in America.
So getting back to how do you
make your business, you have
to have these little things,
little things to intertwine to
help you pay the bills.
Books help you get on TV and
get into Google, into
Microsoft and the Starbucks
campuses, and so I get to
spread your message.
Where we end up,
I have no idea.
We're starting a new grocery
line called Home Remedy right
now, which may or may not show
up, depending on how well it
tells the Seattle, in your
Draeger's Markets, in your
local grocery stores.
Who knows?
It's time to explore.
I've been doing the restaurant
thing for 25 years.
It's time to try a couple of
new things, so we're really
researching that right now.
Thank you all for coming and
spending some of your
afternoon with me.
I appreciate it.
Where do they sign
up for books?
AUDIENCE: So, they're
forthcoming.
But first of all, we
wanted to thank you
for coming to Google.
So thank you very much, Tom.
[APPLAUSE]